il y avait une cave qui ressortissent et
kelly qui a fait tourner la tête d'un
footballeur très célèbre donc salariés
il ya quelques mois vous mais ça aurait
bien tragique sans des pulls ou vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus ce qui
paraît que c'est vous qui avez fait
cette poucave absolue obasi l'anonymat
et bien je ne pas tomber parce que vous
adressez à moi absolument d'accord
bah on le sait en même temps qu'il est
elle s'est tournée à pas mal de temps
alors là je suis au courant j'aimerais
ça va quand même et ça s'est passé cette
semaine
alors il ya un footballeur célèbre wii
capota membres a pas qu'à vous ah ouais
vous l'adorez oui et vous le rend très
très bien mais c'est vrai oui je crois
qu'à l'international on ne dit pas assez
ben on va dire qu'il prendra contact
avec vous une carriole et très bons
contacts c'est parce qu'elle est très
timide
d'accord elle prendra contact n'ont pas
non plus parce que je pense qu'elle ne
sera pas du tout intéressé donc ce n'est
en tout cas pas ce que c'est
c'est en français d'accord les joueurs
et binational qui joue à l'international
c'est un autre enseignant non mais non
pas de bail vient d'avoir un possible
non pas pour balancer débat terre et sur
l'eau oui mais non il est pas
célibataire encore moi là on
on va dire que c'est une rame dit quoi
c'est un grand frère de coeur quoi voilà
comme ça mais moi j'ai beaucoup de
teachers